[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est
science public votre rendez-vous au
quotidien de débat de reportages et
d'analyse sur Public Sénat tous les
jours du lundi au jeudi à 18h et à 22h
nos experts donnent du sens à
l'actualité avec deux débats de 45
minutes que je vous propose d'abord un
débat actuel sera consacré notamment à
la taxe sur les super profil liés à la
crise énergétique hier le président de
la République annoncé l'idée d'un
mécanisme de contribution européenne il
botte en tout chez retard de l'échéance
affirme plusieurs ténors des oppositions
la vie des experts de sciences publiques
dans deux minutes il réagiront aussi à
la polémique du jour peut-on y échapper
l'entraîneur du Paris Saint-Germain qui
blague sur les déplacements du club en
jet privé une mauvaise vanne sur les
chars à voile qui se transforment en
polémique politique et puis chaque jour
cette semaine je vous propose de
décortiquer les grands chantiers de
cette rentrée chantier de réforme hier
c'était l'énergie on va parler de
l'assurance chômage aujourd'hui Emmanuel
Macron veut moduler les allocations en
fonction de la conjoncture économique
s'appelait au patron des patrons
la réforme prioritaire que nous
demandons à votre gouvernement c'est
bien d'adapter les conditions
d'indemnisation au marché de l'emploi il
me semble logique il me semble légitime
que quand il y a beaucoup d'emplois
disponibles la durée d'adminisation soit
réduite et inversement ce système qui
existe au Canada peut-il fonctionner en
France comment expliquer les difficultés
de recrutement des entreprises alors que
2 millions 300 000 Français pointent au
chômage réponse tout à l'heure mais
d'abord donc les réactions à la
proposition du président Macron hier ou
comment remettre la taxe sur les super
profits au cœur de l'actu Samia de chia
des bénéfices records presque insolent
temps de crise
14,8 milliards d'euros pour le
transporteur maritime CMA CGM 10,2
milliards pour Total énergie au premier
semestre 2022 la crise a profité à
plusieurs grandes entreprises des supers
profits que la gauche veut taxer pour
les redistribuer et pour celles et
socialistes veulent en passer par un
référendum d'initiative partagée d'ici
la fin du mois la Nupe va déposer une
proposition de loi si elle est adoptée
par un cinquième des parlementaires il
faudra ensuite obtenir la signature de
4,7 millions d'électeurs en neuf mois
pour déclencher un référendum un
objectif difficile à atteindre mais le
but est surtout de mobiliser l'opinion
publique il faut mettre une pression
maximale sur le gouvernement pour qu'ils
entendent enfin raison dans un moment où
tous nos voisins européens s'y mettent
les uns après les autres les aliens les
Espagnols les Anglais les Allemands si
demain il y a un million de Français qui
disent au président de la République
nous voulons taxer les super profits
pensent que Macron n'irez pas le
gouvernement est encore divisé sur le
sujet Elisabeth borne ne ferme pas la
porte à une taxation des super profits
mais son ministre de l'Économie Bruno Le
Maire lui n'en veut pas une partie des
députés macronistiques et pourtant
favorable tout comme certains
parlementaires de droite qu'il y ait une
contribution exceptionnelle sur ces
entreprises en particulier ça ne me met
pas dans un état second et je le
montrais pas sur la table pour hurler
non non non voilà d'autant que cette
contribution exceptionnelle peut
permettre justement
d'aider à la baisse du prix pour les
consommateurs de l'essence du gaz de
l'électricité pourquoi pas hier Emmanuel
Macron s'est dit favorable à une
taxation des super profits mais
uniquement au niveau européen infaisable
rétorch l'opposition il faudrait pour
cela l'accord de tous les États de
l'Union la droite comme la gauche
l'appel à clarifier proposition
et je vous propose trois grands
chapitres dans ce premier débat de
sciences publiques la taxe sur les super
profits on y vient tout de suite la
polémique sur les jets privés relancer
donc par cette mauvaise blague de
l'entraîneur du PSG et puis l'ouverture
des journées parlementaires du parti
Renaissance j'accueille anne-charles
bézina bonsoir bienvenue anne-charlaine
de vous retrouver constitutionnaliste et
maître de conférences en droit public
Mireille chirolo Assouline bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
économiste de l'environnement professeur
à l'Université Paris impanté en Sorbonne
et à la Paris School of Economics Pascal
Perino bonsoir et bienvenue bonsoir
politologue professeur à Sciences Po
Paris et Laetitia cruppa évidemment
éditorialiste politique bonsoir Laetitia
heureux de vous retrouver tous les
mardis tous les jeudis dans sens public
à ce poste éditorialiste on veut on peut
peut-être commencer par faire un peu de
pédagogie j'aime bien savoir de quoi on
parle dans cette dans cette émission
c'est quoi un super profit un super
profit c'est un profit exceptionnel
mais qui est exceptionnel non pas parce
que les compétences du dirigeants
l'entreprise seraient extraordinaire
parce que la stratégie aurait été
particulièrement clairvoyante mais tout
simplement parce que l'entreprise
bénéficie d'un effet d'aubaine de
circonstances exceptionnelles qui font
que tout d'un coup ces profits sans
qu'elle fasse rien d'autre ses profits
sont bien supérieurs à ce qu'ils étaient
dans le passé c'est le cas de total
c'est le cas de Total pas seulement
total d'ailleurs on a cité d'autres
entreprises dans le dans le sujet de
Samia dechyre mais c'est celle qui est
la plus emblématique oui elle
emblématique et quand on regarde
l'évolution de ces profits là avant de
venir j'avais pas beaucoup de temps pour
le faire mais j'ai essayé de regarder la
chronique des profits total on constate
que au premier semestre 2022 ils ont
fait autant de profits pendant toute
l'année 2021 ou déjà les profits avaient
été augmentés de 50% par rapport à la
moyenne des trois années de 2017 à 2019
je mets à part l'année 2020 où ils ont
fait un profit plus faible mais un
profit malgré tout et je reste avec vous
parce que total
propose sur le territoire français une
ristourne sur le sur le carburant donc
on peut considérer que il fait le il
fait sa part c'est très très peu cette
histoire de par rapport à ces super
profils dont vous nous parlez c'est très
peu c'est de l'ordre de 10% de
l'excédent de profit réalisé par Total
alors la logique de cette histoire c'est
c'est quand même que en effet c'est
super profit ont été gagnés sur les
consommateurs ce sont les consommateurs
qui paient infinés
c'est les augmentations de prix de
l'énergie dans tous les dans toutes les
catégories parce que finalement les
énergies fossiles conditionnent les prix
de l'énergie y compris le prix de
l'électricité et donc ce sont les
consommateurs qui paient les prix de
l'énergie de un niveau beaucoup plus
élevé il est normal que il serait normal
que d'une façon ou d'une autre on
compense alors on va voir si
l'une et l'autre vous êtes d'accord avec
cette idée une claque sur les super
profits uncharger sur le plan du droit
ces entreprises elles ont rien à se
reprocher on peut on peut dire ça quoi
j'ai envie de dire en matière de de
fiscalité de constitutionnalité il faut
aussi souvent se méfier des bonnes idées
qui semblent être unanime dans l'opinion
etc parce que en voulant trop bien faire
en essayant être dans la redistribution
en réalité on se rend compte que c'est
bien plus difficile que ce qu'on ne le
crois je pense notamment à ses super
profit vous avez donné une définition
qui est tout à fait impeccable mais
c'est vrai que on se rend compte au
concret que c'est parfois bien plus
difficile de savoir qu'est-ce qui relève
du super profit de ces profits
aléatoires même si comme vous le dites
la distinction c'est l'acte de volonté
mais enfin l'acte de on va dire de
promotion par l'entreprise mais du coup
ça suppose d'avoir non seulement une
définition impeccable mais aussi une
temporalité c'est à dire de dire ce
super profit il va être dû à la
conjoncture par rapport à telle et tel
élément et donc en fait on se rend
compte que c'est plus difficile à mettre
en place que ce qu'on ne croit parce que
ça relève quand même d'une double
imposition de la part de ces de ces
entreprises puisqu'elles sont déjà taxé
sur leur profit c'est le principe de
l'impôt sur les sociétés donc
c'est difficile à mettre en place il
faut pas oublier aussi cette idée que
quand on est dans des impôts
redistributifs on doit jamais passer la
barre de l'impôt confiscatoire qui est
interdit par notre Constitution donc
attention aussi à garder la force
d'initiative de l'entreprise
de réagir je vais vous donner la parole
dans un instant je entendre Pascal
Perino peut-être une analyse un peu plus
politique c'est c'est un très bon
marqueur pour la gauche et notamment
pour la pour la Nupe c'est sur les super
profits bien sûr parce que l'ennemi est
désigné les grandes entreprises qui font
des des profits à des niveaux qui ne
sont pas raisonnables
la méthode punir et ensuite le but la
redistribution vers ceux qui sont en bas
de l'échelle sociale etc donc le roman
si vous voulez d'un tel un pot sur les
super profits peut-être développer en
effet par toute la gauche et on a vu
jusqu'au Parti socialiste qui relève
bien sûr cette initiative on voit que
dès qu'on en arrive dans le campicisif
c'est-à-dire le camp de la majorité même
si c'est une majorité relative les
choses sont plus compliquées parce que
d'abord Renaissance est une force
politique hétéroclite constituée de
différents courants et on le voit bien
madame borne vient de la gauche elle dit
au fond pourquoi pas c'était à étudier
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire vienne à droite
il dit non n'est pas question donc on
voit l'hétérogénéité jusqu'au cœur même
de cette majorité relative quant à la
droite on entendait tout à l'heure le
sénateur
karucci il dit pourquoi pas mais de
manière exceptionnelle il n'est pas
question de mettre dans le dispositif
fiscal français qui est déjà extrêmement
chargé une nouvelle charge qui serait
pérenne et donc ça ne pourrait être dans
la perspective que décrivait le sénateur
karucci que une qui serait une taxe
exceptionnelle liée une conjoncture
particulière parce que au fond si il y a
des supers profits comme vous disiez
tout à l'heure c'est parce que il y a
une conjoncture particulière l'effet
d'aubaine même si c'est difficile de
parler des faits d'aubaine quand il y a
la guerre Laetitia dans cette définition
impeccable que vous nous avez donné en
début madame
alors est-ce que ce sont des dividendes
qui sont reversés aux actionnaires et ça
profite aux salariés des entreprises
avec des primes exceptionnelles
à partir du moment où on affiche les
profits c'est que déjà les rémunérations
des salariés ont été versées par
conséquent
ces profils là ne sont pas allés au
salarié peut-être des primes
exceptionnelles sont adversées mais je
ne suis pas sûr que ce soit le cas et de
façon massive
ces profits devraient servir à
l'investissement c'est ce qu'ils font
d'habitude mais d'habitude totale
réalisée un profit d'environ 3 milliards
de dollars 3 milliards de dollars chaque
chaque trimestre
là nous sommes sur 9 milliards de
dollars par trimestre donc ces multiplié
par 3
et ça me fait réagir par rapport au
terme de d'impôts confiscatoire qui a
été utilisé on imagine que si on taxé
sans taxé à 100% mais si on taxé le
surplus qui est de profit par rapport au
profit observé dans le passé je vois pas
trop en quoi ça pourrait être considéré
comme confiscatoire donc l'argent va
dans la poche des actionnaires ou à
l'investissement il faut juste rappeler
que Total est devenu total énergie et
entre un engager un plan
d'investissement quand même majeur pour
devenir leader des énergies
renouvelables parce qu'ils ont bien
compris que si ça restait concentré
uniquement sur les énergies fossiles ils
iraient dans le mur on peut aussi
considérer que c'est super profit vont
servir à ça
il serviront peut-être à ça il faut pas
oublier que Total énergie continue à
être très impliquée dans les énergies
fossiles continuent à investir à des
nouveaux projets en Afrique en
particulier
par conséquent
la diversification qui est opérée par
Total lui est absolument nécessaire
parce que à long terme de toute façon ce
sera indispensable et il sera plus
possible d'opérer dans les énergies
fossiles mais je ne suis pas sûr que ce
soit la priorité
alors vous l'avez évoqué ce cette idée
cette polémique autour de la des des
super profits il y a eu les divergences
affichées entre Élisabeth borne et Bruno
Le Maire on peut parler d'un caillou
dans la chaussure d'Emmanuel Macron
alors il a peut-être pensé trouver la
parade avec cette idée de de mécanisme
de contribution européenne annoncé hier
je vous propose de réécouter le
président de la République et puis
ensuite la réaction du communiste Fabien
Roussel
nous défendons un mécanisme de
contribution européenne à l'égard qui
serait demandé donc aux opérateurs
énergétiques pour ceux dans les coûts de
production sont très inférieurs au prix
de vente sur le marché et en effet des
bénéfices indus qui sont faits par des
opérateurs de marché aujourd'hui
et la bonne approche c'est qu'une
contribution leur soit demandé au niveau
européen cette contribution pourrait
ensuite être reversée aux États membres
pour financer leur mesure nationale
ciblées la proposition que fait le
président de la République de soumettre
cette possibilité à une décision de la
Commission européenne excusez-moi mais
c'est un petit peu se moquer de nous
parce que quand ça verra le jour quand
ça verra le jour il aura des cheveux
gris notre président de la République on
en aura vu plusieurs d'ici là c'est
comme la taxe mondiale pour lutter
contre l'évasion fiscale s'il faut
attendre que tout le monde soit d'accord
et que la Commission européenne le
décide ça ne se fera pas vous y croyez
pas faut mettre ça à l'oeuvre tout de
suite des le projet de loi de finances
qui sera étudié d'ici un mois à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat vous
pouvez compter et les Français peuvent
compter sur les députés les sénateurs
les sénatrices communistes pour défendre
une contribution sur les super profits
des multinationales
pas seulement celle de l’énergie mais
celle qui sont parmi les mieux cotés en
bourse les 40 groupes français les mieux
comptés en bourse le CAC 40 alors il y a
plusieurs idées sur lesquelles on peut
rebondir il y a effectivement l'action
du cadre européen il y a la question de
la durée qui pourrait prendre cette
contribution mais je voudrais d'abord
être sur l'aspect politique parce
qu'elle périr parce que on peut se dire
qu'avec cette proposition cette
conférence de presse d'Emmanuel Macron
bah il relance ce que je disais en titre
il relance la machine à polémique alors
il pouvait pas rester inerte sans doute
mais voilà c'est reparti quoi et oui
c'est reparti et une fois de plus il
offre à la gauche
nu-pied nu-péisée c'est comment dire
vous dites pas tout utiliser
la gauche non de valeur le toutou ici
mais il offre une fois de plus un moyen
de créer une unité dans cette gauche qui
ne connaît pas d'unité profonde et en
effet là sur le terrain fiscal de la
redistribution etc la gauche ne peut
faire que ne peut que serrer les rangs
et on sait très bien Fabien Roussel
d'ailleurs d'une certaine manière le
disait on sait très bien que l'idée du
contribution européenne c'est tout
simplement repousser le problème mais
pas dans deux mois dans un an deux ans
trois ans etc et quand on regarde les
principales puissants européennes autour
de nous ça y est il y a déjà ici et là
dans de nombreux pays Espagne Italie des
taxes qui ont été créés l'Allemagne
également des taxes qui ont été créées
donc il y aurait rien d'exceptionnel à
avoir une taxe reste à savoir à quel
niveau et sur quel type de profit mais
alors effectivement et ça rejoint ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure je voudrais
vous vous entendre là-dessus sur la
faisabilité ou la complexité de la mise
en oeuvre d'une telle taxe sur les super
profils est-ce que si c'est si compliqué
que ça alors la complexité est à
plusieurs niveaux c'est à dire il y a
d'abord le calcul du super profit donc
on peut imaginer de prendre une moyenne
sur des années précédentes le petit
calcul que j'ai fait tout à l'heure
enfin on le raffinant mais on peut
imaginer ça ensuite il y a quand même le
problème de du territoire sur lequel ces
profits sont réalisés et le fait que la
plupart des entreprises qui sont
concernées sont des multinationales
forcément ça contribue à la difficulté
d'autant plus que ces multinationales
comme les compagnies d'exploitation
pétrolière enfin ou d'autres énergies
fossiles
réalise une grande partie de leur profit
dans les pays où elles extraient ses
ressources et Paix déjà des impôts à ces
pays-là et la plupart du temps il y a
des conventions fiscales et je suis pas
très sûr qu'il soit possible de taxer ce
profit ce qui me fait penser que
peut-être mais alors là je ne suis pas
fiscaliste et je lance une perche son
hypothèse voilà je me demande si appeler
sa contribution et
prendre comme raison de prélever la
contribution le profit de l'ensemble de
la multinationale mais quelques et
calculer la contribution en fonction de
ça mais ne pas l'appeler taxe et c'est
pas une façon de contourner cette
difficulté de contourner sa difficulté
ce qui serait peut-être aussi une façon
de contourner la difficulté de
l'unanimité au niveau européen voilà
mais même dans le gouvernement
c'est-à-dire si Emmanuel Macron ne veut
pas mettre en place cette taxe qui peut
le forcer
c'est en fait il faut un moment c'est
bien Emmanuel Macron qui décide de la
politique en France bien que les membres
du gouvernement soient peut-être
dissonant mais enfin une fine et c'est
quand même le président de la République
qui décide oui ou non est-ce qu'il y a
des moyens
outre peut-être la pression de l'opinion
publique de faire monter ce sujet et que
l'opinion publique s'en empare et que
bon ça on l'a vu souvent dans des sujets
comme ça societo finalement l'exécutif
pli mais sinon quels sont les moyens de
pression sur le chef de l'étain
finalement puisque c'est ce que menace
l'opposition alors principe d'une
opposition c'est qu'elle est pas
majoritaire bien sûr mais comme vous
dites cette proposition accentuer
d'éventuelles fractures au sein de
notamment
elle peut quand même avoir aussi une
grande place dans l'opinion je revenais
sur le terme de contribution ou taxes il
y a quelqu'un qui se méprendrait pas sur
ce changement de vocabulaire quel
conseil constitutionnel qui nous connaît
que les impositions toute nature au sens
de l'article 34 et qu'on les appelle
taxe contribution amusement ou autre ça
ne le ça ne malheureusement ça ne change
pas son caractère de taxe mais vous avez
raison par contre de parler du motif de
la solidarité et c'est uniquement
là-dessus d'ailleurs que les économies
européennes table l'Allemagne l'Italie
et l'Espagne parce que
constitutionnellement il y a un principe
de solidarité des génération et de
solidarité des Français qui a son impact
donc si elle est temporelle et qu'elle
est exceptionnelle notamment sur la
frange de profit réalisé et attention
uniquement en France vous l'avez dit par
rapport aux conventions fiscales
évidemment cette axe pourrait voir le
jour parce qu'il faut rajouter que c'est
pour ça que je parlais d'un pot
confiscatoire c'est que c'est une
surtaxe qui s'ajoute déjà à l'impôt sur
les sociétés et le Conseil fonctionnel
quand il parle de l'impôt confiscatoire
regarde la globalité des prélèvements
obligatoires sur un même revenu donc il
y a beaucoup d'écueils il y a beaucoup
en réalité il y a une ligne de crête
très mince mais le soutien de l'opinion
est comme vous le disiez c'est pas
uniquement une coloration à gauche c'est
quelque chose d'assez populaire l'un
pour Robin des Bois on a toujours une
assise dans l'opinion quand on parle de
ça donc le fait de relancer de la part
d'Emmanuel Macron alors relancer auprès
de l'Union européenne d'ailleurs Fabien
Roussel nous parle du projet axis qui
est en réalité et sur la table depuis
2001 donc c'est sûr que il y a
l'unanimité donc c'est à peu près
certain de ne pas voir le jour donc il y
a une manière de repousser mais je pense
qu'en tout cas la
sentiment populaire et danger sur ces
questions là et peut tout à fait amener
à ce qu'on repose la question sur la
question sur le tempo si on était dans
ce cadre européen est-ce que finalement
ce n'est même pas les cheveux blancs
j'aurais perdu mes cheveux quand ça sera
quand ça sera vraiment opérationnel
alors il faut obtenir une unanimité la
question c'est qui sera d'accord pour
déjà il faut se mettre d'accord sur des
termes fiscaux sur des normes comptables
c'est des choses qu'on a pas réussi à
faire pour l'impôt sur les sociétés qui
pourtant a pas beaucoup divergences
entre les États de l'Union donc comment
arriver à créer une surtaxe sur un impôt
qui n'est déjà pas commun a priori je
pense qu'on aura tous perdu nos cheveux
alors dans ce débat sur la sobriété
énergétique la polémique sur les jet
privé et plus généralement la pollution
du transport aérien elle vient vous le
savez vous vu passer à côté de cette
vidéo je ne pense pas cette mauvaise
blague de l'entraîneur du Paris
Saint-Germain depuis samedi on
reprochait au club parisien d'avoir pris
un jet faut aller jouer à Nantes et
voilà ce que Christophe Galtier a
répondu hier
excusez-moi
je me doutais qu'on allait avoir cette
question là
pour être très honnête avec vous ce
matin on a parlé avec
la société qui organise nos déplacements
est en train de voir si on peut pas se
déplacer en char à voile
alors il y a le fou rire de Kylian
Mbappe il y a cette blague qui à mon
avis on pourra en discuter a été préparé
parce qu'elle est comme pour tout ce qui
touche au football et surtout à des
stars comme quand même Mbappé ça prend
une dimension politique est-ce qu'elle
est surdimensionnée cette politique
cette polémique pour vous ou pas oui un
peu un peu un peu surdimensionné on sent
bien la rentrée il y a pas beaucoup de
thèmes parfois un peu croquignolet là on
en a bon et puis on a des vedette en
effet Kylian Mbappe hilar couché sur son
bureau bon il y a tout pour faire le
buzz
cependant on essaie de donner un peu de
ces d'autres objectifs ici un peu de
sens un peu de profondeur cependant on
s'aperçoit que chez les citoyens ce sont
des citoyens comme les autres monsieur
Mbappé et l'entraîneur
chez les citoyens et chez les
responsables
l'idée de changer quelques pratiques
trop dispendieuses en matière d'énergie
et véritablement difficile quand on
regarde ça le chemin a parcourir et
littéralement immense parce que ça
suscite de lilas de l'hilarité on sent
très bien qu'il n'en n'ont rien à cirer
des changements de comportement hors
pourtant voilà il est urgent de ne pas
simplement attendre des mesures d'en
haut mais de changer ses propres
pratiques de nous faire évoluer il
s'agit pas de changer de vie mais de les
faire évoluer et là on sent très bien
qu'il y a des gens qui freinent des
quatre faits et ça c'est assez
préoccupant oui oui je suis 100%
d'accord avec vous moi je trouve ça
révélateur ils vivent un peu moi je suis
fan de football donc je m'extasie devant
leurs exploits je vais pas faire
semblant mais ils vivent quand même dans
un monde parallèle le jet privé c'est la
trottinette quoi pour un joueur de foot
à ce niveau de salaire anne-charles
Bizer moi c'est ça ce que je trouve de
révélateur dans cette vidéo les
footballeurs sont en fait des objets
juridiques très identifiés parce que
c'est à cause d'eux qu'on a eu la
surtaxe Hollande qui devait être à 75%
le risque du coup on avait parlé d'un
footballeur dont je ne me souviendrai
jamais du nom mais qui a une petite
queue de cheval je pense à me souviens
plus du tout mais qui avait un
Ibrahimovic exactement le salaire
absolument mirobolant et donc c'est à
partir de là qu'on a créé cette
polémique maintenant eux créer une
polémique sur l'énergie pourquoi parce
que ils sont représentatifs déjà d'un
sentiment d'être français c'est-à-dire
que quand on a les coupes du monde on a
à nouveau l'unité donc on a le sentiment
que ce sont des représentants pour notre
jeunesse et à ce moment-là quand il
véhicule des messages et bien on attend
deux la même exemplarité qu'on ne
réclame de nos gouvernants aujourd'hui
c'est à dire il y a aussi dans la norme
en tant que jury sont on distingue
souvent cela le droit pur et
l'acceptabilité sociale et on se rend
compte ici que un simple débordement qui
aurait pu faire rire certains
aujourd'hui Peut-On rire de tout on
serait dans le des proches ici et bien
on se rend compte que non parce que
précisément il y a la notion
d'acceptabilité et
qui va faire rire les joueurs mais mais
là elle en plus elle semble un peu
préparée on est dans une dose de de
français de faire des efforts où on
demande du collectif et finalement tous
ceux qui vont s'extraire du collectif
c'est un peu le même sentiment qu'on a
eu pour ceux qui ne portaient pas le
masque correctement au moment où nous on
nous oblige d'être à la maison c'est
toujours un peu ça c'est à dire est-ce
qu'on tolère des autres quelque chose
qui rompt l'égalité de tous avec vous
Thomas c'est pas préparé ce n'est pas
possible voilà c'est très mal c'est très
mal préparé s'il y a vraiment un
responsable de communication derrière
cette blague peut-être que c'est préparé
entre eux c'est-à-dire qu'ils se sont
fait cette blague dans les vestiaires
à analyser la vidéo mais mais le fait
que Kylian Mbappé rit avant même que
peut-être la blague il a bien déjà
entendu être mais ce n'est peut-être pas
orchestré par une personne qui s'occupe
de la communication du PSG du
footballeur parce que sinon ce serait
vraiment un conseil absolument
catastrophique enfin voilà et et
pourquoi ça prend une dimension aussi
parce que la ministre des Sports Thomas
réagi directement sur Twitter oui et
interpelle monsieur Galtier on en parle
et toute la classe politique qui a un
petit florilège on va commencer par la
première ministre Elisabeth borne qui
appelle à une prise de conscience je
pense que c'est important qu'il réalise
dans quel monde on est qui prennent
conscience qu'il y a une crise
climatique qui n'est plus une hypothèse
pour demain mais qui est une réalité
maintenant qu'on a tous vécu avec la
canicule avec la sécheresse avec les
incendies cet été et que chacun chacun
doit être bien conscient du monde dans
lequel on vit donc moi je les appelle à
prendre pleinement conscience de cette
situation alors je pourrais passer les
20 minutes qui nous restent dans ce
débat enchaîner les réactions politiques
je vous en propose juste deux autres
celle de Anne Hidalgo maire de Paris
forcément un petit peu Gédé aux
entournures réaction sur Twitter non
mais ça va pas de répondre des trucs
pareils on se réveille les gars ici
c'est Paris elle rappelle quand même
qu'elle est supportrice du club Flo de
critique et daniation il y a assez peu
de voix pour les défendre celle d'Éric
ciotique candidat à la présidente des
républicains il était sur RTL ce matin
je connais bien Christophe Galtier il a
été l'entraîneur de l'OGC Nice on a le
droit un peu à l'humour dans ce monde
cessé de l'ironie enfin en tout cas j'en
ferais pas une histoire tout ça c'est de
l'anecdote par rapport à la gravité du
sujet on résoudra les problèmes
climatiques par une politique à long
terme par la recherche par la science
par le progrès et pas par ces petites
polémiques lorsqu'on a aujourd'hui 32
réacteurs nucléaires à l'arrêt c'est ça
qui nous met en difficulté c'est pas les
trajets du PSG
Mireille Assouline je voudrais je
rappelle que vous êtes économiste de
l'environnement peut-être venir au point
de départ parce que avant cette
polémique il y a une polémique sur les
jets privés notamment les jets privés
utilisés par certains grands patrons ça
pèse quoi les jets privés comme impact
climatique déjà pour remettre les choses
en perspective ça pèse très peu c'est
vraiment ça pèse très peu
il me semble que c'est moins moins d'1%
des émissions totales
voilà c'est pour ça je disais moins d'1%
pour être sûr d'être du bon côté mais
après il y a la charge voilà c'est pas
le sujet c'est-à-dire que dans un
contexte où il faut absolument que
certains responsables politiques ont dit
que c'était le sujet mais bien sûr mais
parce que
les Verts qui laissait entendre que
c'était une chanson de régler de régler
la question quoi on a les deux
utilisations de de l'impact on a d'un
côté certains qui ont insisté sur le
fait que ça aurait un impact important
pour pour venir à l'appui de la mesure
qu'il demandait c'est exagéré maintenant
c'est exagéré en termes d'impact
maintenant il y a une véritable raison
de réduire ses émissions parce qu'il
faut que tout le monde réduise ses
émissions et qu'il y a pas de raison que
certains que certains secteurs y
échappent et puis de l'autre côté
certains ont évoqué le fait que l'impact
était très faible pour dire ça ne sert à
rien mais ça c'est le même argument que
de dire ça ne sert à rien que moi je
fasse des efforts parce que d'autres
n'en font pas et donc ils font pas
tomber
il faut pas tomber là dedans ce qui est
vrai c'est que les jets privés c'est une
c'est une petite partie de l'aviation
commerciale on a tendance à penser que
les jets privés ce n'est pas de
l'aviation commerciale alors pourquoi je
j'insiste sur le fait que c'est de
l'aviation commerciale parce que
l'aviation commerciale est exonérée de
taxes sur le carburant
que vous nous expliquez ça il y a pas de
taxes sur le kérosène il n'y a pas de TI
CPE c'est à dire la taxe intérieure sur
la consommation des produits
énergétiques sur le kérosène pour
différentes raisons au niveau
international parce que ce sont des
accords internationaux qui qui ont fait
que les pays se sont accordés à la
sortie de la de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale sur le fait qu'il n'y aurait
pas de taxes sur les sur les carburants
sur les vols internationaux sur les vols
domestiques en Europe tout pays pourrait
décider de mettre en en place une taxe
sur ses vols domestiques ce n'est pas
fait ce n'est pas fait et c'est vrai
aussi pour les jets privés parce que
quand on dit le jet privé de tels grands
patrons en fait la plupart du temps
c'est jet sont possédés par
l'intermédiaire de société ou de holding
et dès l'instant où les vols ont lieu
contre rémunération contre contrat de
location ce qui se passe effectivement
ce sont des vols commerciaux exonérés
seule l'aviation de loisirs n'est pas
exonérée donc on pourrait commencer par
taxer le kérosène allez on va continuer
sur ce débat avec Tam traduit je propose
terme de nous rejoindre bonsoir tant
pour la question c'est parmi les clubs
de foot qui prend le train et ben il y
en a un comme quoi c'est possible on va
aller pas très loin il y a pas très
longtemps en France pas plus loin que le
week-end dernier et bien les Girondins
de Bordeaux ont fait le déplacement en
train pour affronter le Paris FC vous
allez me dire on joue pas tout à fait
dans la même catégorie que le PSG en
Ligue 2 mais bon c'est ce que vous aviez
envie de dire mais bon comme quoi
possible et si on élargit un petit peu
si on regarde en Europe les bêtises
Séville qui jouent en première division
espagnole a conclu un accord pour faire
lui tous les déplacements de la saison
en train et sans aller jusque là
certains clubs ont opté pour le train
pour des déplacements similaires à un
déplacement comme Paris-Nantes le club
de Liverpool début août a choisi le rail
pour se rendre à fullham sur un
déplacement de 300 km les clubs de
Manchester City de Manchester United là
on monte quand même en gamme on est au
niveau du PSG exactement choisissent
aussi parfois le train
idem pour l'AS Roma
idem pour la Juventus de Turin on va le
voir également sur une photo la Juventus
de Turin que le PSG affronte d'ailleurs
ce soir effectivement on va suivre ça
prendre le train pour un club de foot
c'est donc possible mais c'est quand
même rarement l'option choisie et oui
selon la Ligue de foot professionnel sur
l'ensemble de la saison 2019-2020 en
France seulement il y a eu 65% des
trajets qui ont été effectués en avion
ça fait donc plus des deux tiers des
trajets 31% et seulement 4% en train
alors pourquoi si peu de déplacement
train alors le PSG a essayé d'expliquer
il y a des problèmes de sécurité de
logistique ah oui c'est compliqué pour
les joueurs de se rendre gare
Montparnasse avec vous et moi reste que
bien des options sont possibles à
regarder par exemple ce que propose la
SNCF tout un service de privatisation
des trains avec possible accueil VIP et
privatisé avec tapis rouge train aux
couleurs du club milliardisant tout le
tout team Thomas et même un train aux
couleurs du Hellfest il y avait existé
en 2019 pour se rendre au célèbre
festival de métal ça coûte autour de
30000 euros pour une privatisation de
base et donc accessible pour un club de
foot et puis je le disais tout cela
intervient dans ce contexte de polémique
autour des jets privés il faut dire que
les politiques ne sont pas en reste noté
par exemple le 29 août le média basta
Maga comptabilisé les déplacements des
six jets de la République les six Falcon
de la République depuis le 1er 2022 pas
moins de 280 volts 800 tonnes de CO2 72
années de vie pour de l'empreinte
carbone moyenne d'un Français là encore
le gouvernement a pu à peu près la même
argumentation sécurité logistique
problème d'emploi du temps puis pour
revenir tout de même au foot puisque
c'est le sujet de cette chronique
vendredi l'association altermondialiste
attaque a pointé du doigt l'attitude de
Lionel Messi lui aussi joueur du PSG
dont le jet Privat a effectué 52 vols
depuis le mois de juin soit 1502 tonnes
de CO2 autant qu'un Français en 150 ans
à souligner l'organisation des enquêtes
qui s'inscrivent dans un contexte où le
gouvernement appelle à la sobriété avec
la crise de l'énergie la crise en
Ukraine le réchauffement climatique et
les déplacements en jet privé des
grandes Semoun font forcément grincer
des dents comme de symboles le symbole
d'un effort à deux vitesses merci Tom
pour toutes ces explications à tout à
l'heure dans notre second débat une
dernière information sur sur ce thème
une information de la rédaction de de
Public Sénat puisque le groupe Europe
Écologie vert au Sénat va déposer une
proposition de loi pour
interdire les déplacements en avion
quand il y a une alternative en train à
moi de deux heures et demie le même
principe que pour le grand public cet
article il est à lire sur notre site sur
public sénat.fr et signé Simon barbarie
voilà pour
cette polémique je voudrais qu'on
termine il nous reste quoi une douzaine
de minutes c'est parfait ce premier
débat de sciences publiques avec les
journées parlementaires de renaissance
nouveau parti de la majorité
présidentielle Laetitia alors vous
trouvez cet événement un petit peu
bancal oui Thomas pour la simple et
bonne raison que formellement le parti
Renaissance n'existe pas encore c'est
son secrétaire général dans Stéphane
séjourné un proche d'Emmanuel Macron et
qui est encore heureux député qui l'a
annoncé dans les colonnes du Parisien la
semaine dernière il l'a dit le lancement
se fera au Louvre le 17
septembre et puis depuis qu'Emmanuel
Macron finalement a annoncé la création
de ce nouveau parti je ne sais pas vous
Thomas mais moi je me pose quand même
cette question qui me taraude tout l'été
pourquoi un nouveau parti présidentielle
alors que la République en marche n'a
que 5 ans vous avez vu cette question il
faut débrancher pendant les vacances
quand même Laetitia mais j'ai eu un
élément de
réponse autant Elizabeth borne qui
visiblement a déjà pris sa carte fictive
du parti c'était le 27 août elle était
lors de ce séminaire là de rentrer avec
les cadres de justement de la République
en marche à Metz écoutez là comme chef
de la majorité comme militante vous
pourrez compter sur mon engagement ma
détermination et ma présence bâtissons
notre renaissance
bâtissons notre maison du dépassement
bâtissons cette maison commune avec tous
ceux qui veulent agir au service des
Français au service de notre pays au
service de l'Europe et en écoutant ça
tout à l'heure nous irons de bois bah
oui enfin je veux dire elle dit tout et
rien falloir son discours est totalement
vide je ne comprends toujours pas
pourquoi la République en marche doit
être remplacée par Renaissance alors
Stéphane séjourné a donné quelques
éléments de réponse il reconnaît
finalement qu'il y a deux manquements
dans le parti d'Emmanuel Macron
finalement de failles c'est vrai il n'y
a pas d'ancrage territorial en 5 ans ils
n'ont pas réussi à avoir des relais
locaux et puis une faible participation
aussi au débat d'idées il a déjà dévoilé
un peu ses secrétaires adjoints alors
presque pas de surprise sauf Pascal
confin à qui apparemment n'aurait jamais
adhérer à aucun parti politique c'est
pas non plus la prise de guerre de
l'année donc on va attendre le 17
septembre et puis on verra pourquoi
Renaissance est créée mais en tout cas
la communication politique autour de ces
journées parlementaires a déjà bien
diffusé dans la presse on a compris que
ils allaient plancher là sur les sujets
portés par Emmanuel Macron pendant la
campagne le travail le plein emploi la
souveraineté de la France l'Union
européenne et la transition écologique
et la démocratie autre info officielle
il n'y a pas de people pas de stars dans
ces deux jours nés parlementaires mais
des experts qui vont venir former
formation express à 48 heures les
nouveaux parlementaires assez grands
sujets qui ont déjà eu droit à un
briefing en off c'est plutôt en off
alors c'est dans le sillage personne ne
l'a raté du discours grave du chef de
l'État la fin de l'abondance la fin de
l'insouciance on a bien dit au
parlementaire pas de lyrisme cette fois
on n'est plus en 2017 c'est plus la
révolution va pas renverser la table
comme disait Emmanuel Macron là c'est la
sobriété alors certaines langues se sont
quand même un petit peu déliées on a lu
dans le Figaro par exemple que les
certains incertains étaient pétris de
doute oui parce qu'en fait ils savent
pas du tout comment ça va se passer
qu'elles vont être les relations entre
le Parlement et l'exécutif et puis il y
a aussi cette petite phrase d'Emmanuel
Macron qui n'a pas prononcé le mot de
dissolution mais quand même quoi il a
reçu les perdants au législatives la
semaine dernière à l'Elysée il a dit il
y aura d'autres combats donc finalement
tout le monde s'est dit il peut-être
qu'il y aura une dissolution et puis les
lieutenants étaient envoyés dans les
médias pour éteindre le feu comme Aurore
berger
de la dissolution vous savez il s'est
beaucoup évaporé cet été est-ce qu'on a
démontré la capacité qu'on avait à tenir
et on a démontré la capacité qu'on avait
à faire adopter les projets de loi
notamment sur la protection du pouvoir
d'achat des Français alors je vais
reprendre finalement l'interrogation
estivale de Laetitia parce qu'elle
Perrineau pourquoi créer un nouveau
parti c'est quoi c'est l'accélération du
temps politique ça se démonétise de plus
en plus vite un parc bien sûr les partis
politiques c'est la monnaie la plus
rejetée aujourd'hui en France quand vous
regardez les baromètres à la fin de
toutes les institutions quelles qu'elles
soient économiques ou autre pour
médiatique aussi Lionel médiatique et
rassurez-vous c'est formidable vous êtes
légèrement devant on est avant dernier
c'est ça donc voilà c'est très
démonétisé d'autre part il y a une
tradition française
d'extraordinaire volatilité des parties
regardez l'histoire du mouvement
gaulliste par exemple ils ont sans arrêt
changer de nom RPF unr unr hudr
voyez ça ça sans arrêt changer de nom
pour aujourd'hui se retrouver dans LR et
on prendrait le Parti socialiste et la
même chose ça s'appelait ses filles au
Havre ça s'appelait nouveau parti
socialiste donc c'est une manille
franco-française et qui tient en fait
que les parties Français n'ont jamais
été de grandes machines implantées dans
la société avec une pérennité des
étiquettes du personnel ça a été
toujours de toutes petites organisations
extrêmement volatiles dans tous les sens
du terme on vous entendant je fais le
parallèle avec les parties les grands
partis américains
en Grande-Bretagne le Parti populaire en
Espagne oui c'est des grandes formations
politiques or là les marques françaises
sont très faibles sont incroyablement
faibles et puis il y a je crois aussi
l'idée que maintenant chez les
macroniens on se pose la question de du
macronisme sans Macron puisqu'il ne
s'arra pas ils ne peut pas être une
troisième fois candidat et donc il y a
dans le passage de lrem à Renaissance il
y a une forme de dépersonnalisation il
n'y a plus le em ça avait commencé
d'ailleurs comme ça voilà en marche puis
la République en marche maintenant c'est
Renaissance et il y a la tentation et la
tentative dans le silence présidentiel
avec un président qui ne donne pas de
Gap hein c'est frappant depuis sa
victoire il ne donne pas de cap à la
majorité et bien de dire voilà on a un
cap c'est la Renaissance alors la
Renaissance c'est en effet extrêmement
ouvert vous pousse chacun y met ce qu'il
veut
voilà quelque chose et ma grenier de
droite ils mettent autre chose et voilà
c'est un peu l'auberge espagnole alors
que dans la macronie il y a tout de même
des parties qui sont en ordre de marche
et en particulier horizon mais c'est
vrai des macroniens pur auront besoin
devant la velléité et même la volonté
d'horizon de mettre en place son
présidentiable d'une machine qui le
moment venu sera capable de faire cela
alors on était évidemment assez à
l'ouverture de ces journées
parlementaires je vous propose
d'entendre l'une des réactions celles de
François Patriat priant du groupe
rassemblement démocrate progrès systèmes
indépendant ici au Sénat écoutez nous
avons vécu les passé simple nous allons
connaître le futur difficile voilà bien
là ce que je dirais demain nos amis nous
avions une majorité confortable mais sur
la ligne et celle qu'on pouvait tenir de
façon maintenant aujourd'hui même dans
le futur composé on peut pas dire le
futur simple c'est-à-dire composé
puisque nous allons devoir passer des
compromis alors moi je sais vous
comprenez bien que au-delà de résultats
des élections contexte dans lequel nous
venons de rentrer est un contexte à la
fois où le drame dramatique est là vous
les difficultés sont nombreuses
dans ma vie politique j'ai rarement vu
en même temps à la fois une crise
j'allais dire la guerre crise de
l'énergie un manque de matière première
une crise de l'écologie
jumelée bon l'air des futurs du futur
difficile mais effectivement il y a
cette ombre là cette absence était
Édouard Philippe bézina qui est sur un
thème pot qui est clairement pas celui
du président de la République il sera
par exemple jeudi il sera pas au conseil
au CNR Conseil national de la
refondation il est au Canada je ne doute
pas de l'importance de ce qui va faire
au Canada mais la stratégie d'Édouard
Philippe se contretant se contretempo
d'une certaine façon comment vous
l'analysez et bien il faut une
succession on a donné toutes les
caractéristiques de nos parties français
mais on oublie aussi la personnalisation
extrême vous en avez parlé la
personnalisation des partis politiques
c'était et c'est le cas avec le parti Go
lise et le parti macronien c'est-à-dire
que on a l'habitude d'avoir des parties
par rapport à un chef c'est ce culte que
nous avons en France et les filles c'est
finalement l'enfant de Mélenchon le
rassemblement national qu'il le veuille
ou non c'est évidemment la nouvelle
mouture du Front national donc on ne se
départit pas finalement de cette
coloration du chef et donc Renaissance
c'est censé permettre à Edouard Philippe
de d'émerger tranquillement comme étant
affilié au bilan du passé et du passif
sans en être trop débiteur non plus donc
on est dans une quadrature du cercle qui
est toujours celle de l'avenir
finalement du président
ne fait pas partie de renaissance
Renaissance et agir le type du centre et
puis territoire Hippocrate était à
gauche donc il fait bien de la majorité
parlementaire mais Stéphane séjourner
encore une fois dans cette interview aux
Parisiens a bien dit et affirmé que ce
parti Renaissance servirait à présenter
un candidat en 2027 or horizon
présentera aussi vraisemblablement son
candidat donc il y aura deux candidats
de cette maison commune pour rappeler
c'était aussi cet élément de langage
qu'on nous avait servi juste dans la
vague de la présidentielle la maison
commune bon ben il a quitté la maison et
puis un peu d'amertume exprimé par
Emmanuel Macron c'est son au contraire
du point qui révèle ça le confort du
point qui qui nous révèle que à dîner ou
justement il avait convié un peu tous
ces Noël personnalités de renaissance il
a dit il aurait dû être là et Édouard il
aurait dû être à cette table et je ne
désespère pas qu'il nous rejoignent
c'est un peu raté pour le moment en tout
cas on va être évidemment dans la
prochaine présidentielle dans dans ce
qu'on a pu avoir en 95 c'est-à-dire en
fait des guerres de succession tout
simplement qui sont en soit saine
puisque au moins ça permet de renouveler
le personnel politique mais encore
faut-il savoir quel est le jeu des
alliances à qui on est fidèle et aussi
qu'est-ce que les Français veulent de
cette incarnation parce que on nous a
dit le macronisme est un pragmatisme
mais précisément un parti politique ne
peut pas non plus être un caméléon
advitaméternam donc il va falloir
trouver un ancrage et surtout trouver un
dialogue pour s'en créer localement et
pour s'en créer au niveau des adhérences
veut pas dire qu'il faut une identité
c'est aujourd'hui un centrisme
nouvelle mouture avec justement des
emprunts un petit peu hybrides comme ça
je suis pas sûr que cette force
politique puisse arriver à centrer dans
l'opinion sans un projet plus clair et
on termine là-dessus merci beaucoup
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à ce premier débat